bah
le cerveau est ce vous pour ville non ce
n'est pas moi
je n'ai pas une tête assez grosse pour
être le cerveau
si jamais tu y est ce vous le cerveau
non mais même
david niven goût le cerveau oui oui moi
je suis le cerveau qui est le cercle
jean paul belmondo a le cerveau
s'appelle que moi
mais est-ce que vous êtes sur 7 le
cerveau je suis parfaitement sûr que je
suis le cerveau mais quelquefois il ya d
autres qui m'ont montpetit entourage les
petites soeurs d'excusés mis au point
mais j'ai mis au point on va refaire le
coup du crapaud stan
c'est en mai borwin là dedans parce
qu'il avait mis un peu trop calme
c'est grâce à mon idée géniale série bat
va devenir très riche quelle est votre
idée géniale et ben
on va s'introduire sur le train et on va
attaquer avec un produit spécial peux
pas révéler mois mais très efficace et
vous êtes vraiment le cerveau avril chez
service que c'est moi qui ai eu cette
idée je suis seul à avoir cette idée car
ça ne l'a eu
car ça n'a eu cette idée
votre projet vous pensé réaliser quand
la date
oui vendredi prochain c'est vrai cette
veine associés oui j'ai associé j'ai pas
envie de m'associer et l'huile et des
chauffeurs de taxi et machete bien qui
sera présenté en mai avec moi dans ce
coup là oui il comprend pas très bien me
suis ensuite gentiment mais là il peut
il peut m'aider beaucoup
pourtant bien contre lui explique dans
son discours il faut l'expliquer
longtemps je recevais tout le temps tout
le temps est ce que ça marche et
m'excuse
est-ce que vous avez des associés oui
j'ai des petits loups sinon les petits
se voter oui ils sont laissés à vous
aussi
la pièce est vous le cerveau et les
voilà je sais pas parce que attention
oui
c'est vrai
oui ni non
ce n'est pas en mettant de faire
d'autres avis jaro remy qu'ils servent
finalement dans ce film cerveau c'est
moi je crois que nous avons écrit
l'histoire et que et que nous là
tournons maintenant alors je pense que
ça doit être un petit peu moi vous sans
aucun doute un sans aucun doute après
les acteurs bien sûr ça ne sera jamais
mois pour le public mais elle savait
plus ou moins au fond et arthur anatole
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont là turenne atomes
sont un petit peu le cerveau à un moment
davini veine les définitivement et il a
avoué l'athlète un moment donc on ne
sait jamais finalement qu'il serve
française d'omar su sauver les voir et
les mystères du théâtre ou du cinéma
l'accord vient de tenter ça finit ont
tourné le film fin octobre il sera monté
novembre décembre janvier je pense qu'il
sortira vers février c'est votre
scénario c'est mon scénario et c'est
notre réalisation notre adaptation et
dialogues à marcel jullian et danièle
thompson et moi-même et moi même comme
aurait dit ça y est